autre manifestation du pcf à lyon cette
fois devant les locaux de l'antenne de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
exiger que les vaccins et les
traitements contre les pandémies
devienne un bien public mondial
accessible à tous une action qui fait
écho à une première demande réclamé en
mai dernier par l' oms réaction au micro
de luis carballo
cette action s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la campagne européenne pas de profit
pour la pandémie qui vise à récolter un
million de signatures afin que la
question soit mise en débat au parlement
européen mais d'une manière plus large
l'idée c'est de dire que sept ans
daniele mondiale les vaccins sont le
fruit d'un travail de la bo du monde
entier mais également de l'avs au public
du monde entier et que donc du coup nous
demandons que les brevets sur les
vaccins soient rendus publics afin que
tout le monde puisse y accéder au prix
le plus bas s'agit d'une question de
santé publique santé mondiale donc en
demandant à pôle public du médicament ça
nous assure d'avoir l'ensemble de la
chaîne des puys la recherche jusqu'à la
production et la distribution à travers
le pays